that was the best thing ever because i
lost my virginity in
the uh hilton hotel in midtown manhattan
as a 17 year old from philadelphia
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who was once picked up for
shoplifting in a bath and body works and
played
dead immediately elise morales and with
us
today we have just a good old pal of
mine a comedian and host who you know
from
hq trivia hq words and her podcast
the unemployed show but before all of
that
she was a graduate of harrington high
school it's anna roisman
hi thank you oh my god i haven't heard
those words in so long graduate
of heritage high school you know uh we
say we say this on the pot a lot but we
worked hard for that high school degree
yeah shout out
i don't think i have my i don't think my
parents have my college
diploma which is probably they're
supposed to have that but they have my
i've seen the high school one
it's like did i even need to go honestly
the high school one is more work
yeah it is it's tougher years
it's it's the most it's honestly the
most concentrated effort
i have personally spent on anything yeah
i agree thanks for having me i'm psyched
to be here
i'm so excited so you you are a veteran
of our live show which for those of you
who listen to the podcast you those who
don't know this was once a live show
when live shows were a thing
um but i'm very excited to dive deeper
into your teen self based on
what i know so first first question i
like to ask is just um
what flavor of high school is heraton
high school
where is it public private what's the
vibe
so harrington high school is a very
small public high school
in the suburbs of philadelphia uh lower
marion school district
is the school district a lot of people
know it because kobe bryant
this got sad kobe bryant was like the
most famous person from my area he went
to
lower marion high school so there's two
high schools okay
i actually remember hearing this in one
of the million
kobe bryant things that i watched after
the sad thing yeah yeah it so
most people know lower marion high
school so there's two high schools in
the district
lower marion is like the big one like
people per class i don't know maybe not
per class but a lot of people yeah
my school hereton also public school
same school district
uh you know it's like on the other side
of like the five towns that we all like
funnel into
um haran was a lot smaller so like even
though it was public school like
there were like 200 kids in a class like
oh wow
yeah because there were less people in
the hair it was like weird it was like
middle schools were pretty
evenly sized and then like a lot more
kids went to laura marion and like
less like public school like middle
school went to
parenting i'm sure if we dug into that
we would find out something bad
i'm just like i'm sure the reason is
probably upsetting
but right i i have no idea my dad went
to herodon though so like that was cool
to go to the high school my dad went too
which yeah was there any like relics of
your
dad around the high school like harry
potter finding his dad's like old
trophies
no definitely not middle school yes i
had like a shop teacher
who like pretended to remember who my
dad was but like
i don't even think he was very old i
don't even think he knew like what day
it was
but he was like ah ricky roisman i
remember him i'm like no he doesn't but
it's so sweet
it's nice to try it's like oh of course
you do
that's that's adorable yeah i definitely
remember my dad
so you took shop where's that like uh
[Music]
did you get to choose between things i
don't remember that was middle school
we all took shop you didn't take shop
and home
oh my god be a shopping home act we did
not take shop but i
did take home ac but homec was called
family and consumer sciences
oh wow um so you were
and i know this from your previous
performances you were a drama girl
i was yeah i found drama though later i
like was
very i did three sports a year i was a
athlete growing up my mom's an athlete
my parents have nothing to do with like
theater or acting or any of that [ __ ] i
knew what i wanted to do
but i like you know i did my sports i
liked i was good i was good at sports
and then like by sports oh so i i'm a
tennis player
primarily that's what i mostly did but i
also played basketball and i played
softball
got it and then like by like ninth grade
i realized or like 10th grade it must
have been ninth grade i realized i can't
play softball
and audition for the spring musical and
like that's where
you know i was divided and that
this has happened many times and that is
ultimately the plot of high school
musical
how does one do sports
and the play it cannot be there it
[Laughter]
what did did you ultimately choose
theater
obviously yeah i chose theater i was
hardcore
um so like i didn't do any of the plays
though in middle school so there were
already like
the drama people who were going it
starts early yeah
but i was doing sports in middle school
and i was friends with like the cool
crowd
and then like come high school i i went
from like cool to like
nerd like very fast um because i was
like i want to do theater which is good
you know i listened to my instincts
um i also played an instrument and that
was like a huge
part of my high school experience what
instrument
i play the alto saxophone that's [ __ ]
cool
i still have it i still can play it uh
thank you extremely cool thing but isn't
cool when you're in high school
like when you're cool yeah when you're
in high school and you tell someone they
play they
you play the alto saxophone that means
nothing to them now i'm like
oh my god that's [ __ ] awesome it's
cool
you know in a lot in some ways um when i
but you decide did you do this like in
school they made us
decide on an instrument in like third
grade or something like i liked the
violin
you like test them out right you like
walk in a room and they're like and
i remember they put on my like form i
said i walked in i was like i want to
play the saxophone because
i want to play an instrument that's in
jazz band but i like knew that already
because i had seen the performances from
the high school and
they said her hands are too small for a
saxophone
and they recommended like the [ __ ]
clarinet or the
the oboe or the flute and i was like um
these are [ __ ] instruments i will play
the cool saxophone my hands will grow
as i get older yeah that's crazy to say
to a child like your hands are gonna
grow
teach this kid the saxophone her hands
will get bigger
i know and then i i was like good at it
i don't know if it was like mentally i
was like i'll
show them but i was like first seat in
the band and i was the only girl in the
whole
jazz band it was all boys and i and so
they let me wear like
we all were all black but they were like
since you're the only girl i guess you
can wear like a cool color i wore like
neon orange like a turtleneck
i was like not only will i stand out
because i'm a girl but i will be the
brightest person in the room
absolutely i am going to stunt on this
jazz band concert
yeah yeah so yeah so then come high
school i was still
i was doing jazz band and concert band
and and concert choir because i sang
too and then i was in the plays so i i
don't think i played i did play tennis
all four years because tennis was in the
fall
somehow i figured out how to do that i
don't know
well that's also a crazy thing to think
about with high school where you're just
like wait so i was going to school for
eight hours a day and then i also was
playing
five sports and i had homework
i don't know i was like doing it yeah i
still and i start in a play
i have no [ __ ] clue it makes
no [ __ ] sense yeah
i didn't get big roles in the plays i
wasn't like a hot shot from the start
and seniority at
my high school was a huge deal so like
freshmen were like chorus you know you
were automatically in the chorus like
unless you were like a child you know
movie star i i don't know
no no younger grades like got the good
rules off the back
you had to be a prodigy yeah that's how
it you
know they said you have to earn your
roles so like you know
by junior year maybe you'll get a lead
like it was
you had to you know yeah that's how
my high school worked but also like my
theater teacher loved to subvert that
and like keep you on your toes by being
like
yeah you might get the role you want
your senior year but also i'm crazy
i could do anything right don't apply
yeah exactly so he's like so you must
please me at all times
and we bent over backwards to do so um
okay so here's a question yeah was
banned like i mean i guess you were the
only girl in the band but was it like
one night at band camp
sexually active band geeks or was it a
very
chaste pursuit so band was
i would say band was like band band
concert band was guys and girls and like
we were like it wasn't as sexually you
know
active and hyped up but we were like bad
where like when we went to play
at like some like six flags or something
like we had like a performance like
people brought alcohol you know what i
mean so we like they were like
cool and like we know how to party no
one was really hooking up
in band maybe they were jazz band was
like
like so jazz band i was the only girl
for a lot of years
i think there ended up being like one
other girl but like and i was younger
and they would like drive me to
practice like early in the morning like
my neighbor was in jazz band he'd like
pick me up
they would like roll joints and they
would like have lots of
weed and i was like this naive like i'm
also a singer
you know
like made through it was like i know i'm
here and i play the saxophone and i'm
very cool but i also am in the musical
and like i can't do that to my lungs
like they were
they always were like trying to get me
to do [ __ ] and like this
band sounds extremely cool i mean
like did you have a jazz band did you if
you went to public we did but i didn't
have really
much of a relationship with the
band people okay i was very much
entrenched in the theater people
and the emo people and we
my freshman year i had i i kind of
switched to my like
core crew of friends was in the middle
of high school the beginning of high
school we called
ourselves the carpet hallway crew and we
sat in the carpet hallway
wow okay and then later
well listen to this we you're gonna
you're gonna see a pattern here
and then later i changed my friend group
to the door two crew
and we stood by door too so
i love how these names just they come to
you and you're just like
yeah honestly that's what we'll do you
were just you know when you're a kid
you are just bubbling with creative
energy
yeah yeah but for me the
the band so like the jazz band members
like a lot of them played in the pit
orchestra for the shows so there was
like
overlap in that way you know what i mean
so like some of my friends from there
were in that
because we never talked to the band into
plays at
all they're like the crew
you guys are like such divas that you're
like oh that's cute the crew's here
we i do not remember us interacting with
the band or the orchestra in
any way but the tech theater tech was
separate at our school
yeah and that was like a lot of
crossover
yeah and like second actors had a lot
of hooking up oh yeah same at high
school that's a very
sexually tense relationship between
theater tech and actor
yeah for sure yeah i remember that being
it too
you spend a lot of time in the dark i
think that's why
and like backstage there's always like
that old couch that like they use
for like props or like set pieces and
you're like ah
like who's gonna have sex on the couch
this year like you know there's always
like weird rooms with like [ __ ]
from yeah and like i feel like the boys
that are in tech are always like
do you want to like come up to the where
the lights are yeah like i can show you
where all the lights are and then you
can really mean girls
yes oh my god i wasn't even thinking
about that but that's that is where they
go in mean girls
right they go to projector room which is
like the tech booth yeah
we had a prop room where they kept all
the props and costumes that the theater
kids kind of like
the teacher would like let us hang out
in there yeah and there was like
rows and rows of costumes and so like of
course we were making out in there yeah
of course we were so funny
it was that was a beautiful place yeah
we had a name for our theater group it
was called the htc
and it was the heritain theater company
but we were like htc
like i'm in htc it was intense freshman
year i was a chorus girl and crazy for
you
great um sophomore year
what the [ __ ] did we do oh we did god
spell sophomore year
i did god spell once with like an
outside theater group
oh fine i love bloodspell and godspell
because there's not really like elite
aside from like i guess it's judas
and jesus right they're the leads uh
everyone kind of gets a song in god's
spell so like i got a dope
song what song i did turn back oh man oh
that's the best song
and i was like to be the sexy one a
sophomore
[ __ ] yeah and i remember this sounds
okay this sounds insane i remember they
were like i came in through the audience
like i was gonna come through the
audience and like make my way
up to the stage you know what i mean and
like that's how i feel yeah i feel like
that's traditional for god
okay and i and i was like i was so
excited to like be in the audience and
they're gonna have a spotlight on me and
i'm gonna be in a boa and i'm gonna like
[ __ ] you know
i knew how to i knew how to sex it up i
watched a lot of porn as a kid and i was
like
ready for it and i remember being
worried about like they were like and
you can like play with people and
whatever and i was worried about like
sitting on people's laps that like
yeah i didn't know you know like
students and stuff i was like i don't
want to like
you know invade like be in someone's
space
so i remember i like would plant
one of our theater teachers like
he's like a science teacher and i
remember he would like
sit there and like during all the
rehearsals i was like so you'll be there
like even during the
he's like i'll be there for the
performance and i'd go and like sit on
his lap and like put the boa like around
his back
and i think back now and i'm like what a
[ __ ] sick
person that i was and him for uh being
like yeah
i'll be there for every performance yeah
i feel like
i feel like they should have just been
like we're gonna pick
a friend of anna's who's another
student at the school to do this
no but i feel like there is
nothing i would have wanted more in high
school than to book
the sexy role like how did you
how did you take that on emotion well
it's funny because i
i was so excited i liked the song um i
took it
i i loved the costumes i was like yeah
i'm
and i was wearing like a padded bra by
then i was like yeah i should get the
sexy roll i
invested in this bra for victoria's
secret that's like a giant i have giant
tits now
i remember a rear move that was
but then i was typecast always as the
dumb [ __ ]
like even in the play the next year we
did one flew over the cuckoo's nest
and it was like i came back and i was
like you know
i don't there are three girl roles in
that whole play yeah
so i guess i was lucky to get a role but
they were like
she can only play a [ __ ] now and i was
like oh no but i have range
like you should see me at camp yeah
um i was like so at school i was always
like the [ __ ]
role i you know i i did it to the best
of my ability what's funny is i was
the the opposite in life i was like
scared to to kiss a boy
so that's what i was gonna ask like did
this translate
at all into your actual sexual activity
not at all not at all i remember even i
i was
i had a lot of guy friends i think
because i was in band and stuff
and like so a lot of my friends were
guys i didn't really have like a girl
group
or anything in high school middle school
yeah
and then in high school no and i
remember one of my guy friends was like
why are you so prude
i was like what do you mean like
he's like you know all of us would hook
up with you and i was like
you're my friends like i remember
feeling like wait that's what you
i i thought were friends i feel like
that is such a huge
moment even for prom like one of my
friends asked me to prom and i was like
sure i didn't have a boyfriend and i was
like yeah that would be fun to go with
him he's my friend and then like he
cried because i didn't want to kiss him
the night
and i was like i wasn't trying to go out
with you like
i don't want to be in a relationship i
just thought it'd be fun we'd have a fun
prom yeah i mean i was always like
i was at the height of drama in my
romantic relationships at all times i
so like i was always down to play ball
if the friend came up to me and was like
i'm actually in love with you i'd be
like
interesting i guess we can exchange some
i items
[Laughter]
um that's how all the magic happens yeah
i was just like um
i was just one of those girls who was
like desperate to be in a love story and
to be falling in love and like
listening to emo music and just like
breaking my heart open
and like watching the oc and crying
falling off i was just so
in love with love at that time i love
that
i was more career obsessed and i
literally thought
maybe one day i'll have room for a man
but right now
like i auditioned for american idol like
i would watch
i was non-stop like i knew i was like i
don't have time for a boyfriend if i
want to be like
in movies by 20. okay so tell me
everything about auditioning for
american idol oh my god it was the most
insane
thing ever so like um i auditioned at
the javit center
in new york city i didn't live in new
york obviously
i was 17 years old and i remember
like i was in new york visiting a camp
friend or something and i like
heard there were auditions for american
idol and i thought i'll go
i've always loved the show i'll go and i
went and there were 17 000 people in
line
uh little me like 17 year old me like
goes
and i'm like like with a bag like you
know i just go
and get them trying to sign up for the
vaccine and they're like you're number
yeah it's the same [ __ ] and i get online
i'm online
like let's say i got there like 8 a.m
all day okay and people have sleeping
bags and they are prepared to be there
some have been there for days and
i'm like oh my god like i didn't think
it'd be like this i didn't pay attention
we didn't have the
like we had the internet but people
weren't posting like hey
i'm i'm auditioning right now for
american idol like check out this line
like look at how you know yeah and i got
someone came through the line and i got
like a card they give you like a ticket
or whatever when you get to come back
the next day to audition people slept on
the street all night
and uh or i didn't get the i got up to
the guy who gives the cards
and they looked at my id and they're
like you're not 18. you can't audition
without a parent or guardian and i was
like
i've been here nine hours like all day
i'm like sweating in like the outfit i
came in like i'm like
with like a tiny little bag and i
remember i called my mom and i was like
i told her i was doing it
i was like i need a parent or guardian
and god bless my mom she got on an
amtrak from philadelphia came to new
york city
brought sleeping bags and we slept
on the sidewalk that night the guy was
like gave me a tentative card as long as
i like came back with my mom or a parent
or whatever
and she came and she was like we'll have
fun and like we didn't sleep because
people sing 24 hours a day
everyone's practicing constantly
they think they're american nights it
was insane
and like jared from subway was doing
like promo work and i remember he was
like
walking up and down the lines with like
subway signs and [ __ ]
it was such a weird experience and like
so we slept on the street and i remember
you get your card
okay so then the next morning you get
like a time that day and my time was in
the afternoon
so we literally went to like a
department store we went to like
bergdorf goodman to like
shower in their public bathrooms
literally to like sink shower you know
because they have nice
[ __ ] my mom's like well we'll go to
bergdorf's you know my mom's a [ __ ] and
she's like and we'll get lunch and we'll
shower in the sinks
and we ran into like my aunt who's like
what are you doing and she's like
anna's auditioning for america night i
was like mom don't tell people like
we looked like we had slept on the
street yeah
you looked like you had tried to sleep
on the street but everyone was singing
so you couldn't sleep you couldn't sleep
i remember at one point my mom went and
bought herself a bottle of wine because
she's like this will knock me out it was
like drinking wine
like just like a bottle or like man your
mom props to your mom
a ride or die
for real meanwhile you audition you get
through like one round of producers the
next
and then like the producers are they're
not you don't get to the big dogs until
like
eight rounds or something and so like no
one from my group got through they told
me i was good
but they were like you're not reuben
stuttered and
that feedback stuck with me for years
they told you i was like no they told us
17 year old anna roseman you're not
reuben stuttered yeah they were like
you're really good but you know you're
not ruben stuttered and
that's who we're looking you know he's
one of our american idols and i was like
yeah i mean no [ __ ] you're not reuben
stuttered
i'm not uh let's actually
i want to move in because we're talking
now about uh
i guess your early forays into stardom
and i think that this first photo of you
really
puts that on display okay
so this is a gorgeous black and white
photo
of you thank you flower in your hair
this looks like a headshot
is it no so this was taken at my
brother's bar mitzvah
i actually i think i showed this on your
live show once i think i peaked
this is i am 15 here
um and i this is the i still to this day
will be like
this is the prettiest i've ever looked
my hair my dress my makeup i don't know
what
what i did but it's a stunning photo
like you're drop dead it's one of those
pictures where
they're like and this is and this is the
anna royceman's first
photo before she got into vogue
it's so funny to me because i'm like how
did i know how to like get that [ __ ]
done
at 15. like what happened afterwards
there's a lot of awkward afterwards you
know what i mean
and the control in your face the
emotion in your eyes it's really
this this was just out of bar mitzvah
like my brother's bar mitzvah so it was
like a big it was like a fancy
event okay we have these like our bar
mitzvahs in
in our town were like weddings you know
what i mean they were like
it was at a hotel it was like a black
tie
thing this dress is hilarious so this
dress you can't see the full dress i had
it made
uh i had a it was copied after a sarah
jessica parker dress that she wore to
the golden globes
i watched a lot of sex in the city with
my family every sunday night that was
like a
normal sunday night activity for us
which is highly inappropriate
and so many things about that
not appropriate but whatever so yeah i
i had this photo like around like i kept
it around being like
this will be the photo i use for the
rest of my life it's the prettiest i'll
ever look
it's it really is a gorgeous photo and
this isn't even your bar mitzvah
no i had already had the bat mitzvah i
was going to show you that but i was
like no this is more when i'm like 15.
so you know this was when i was in like
what was your bat mitzvah theme though
just so that we know oh so mine was
anna's paradise island
uh i didn't pick it it was you know it
was a lot of
palm trees we had steel drum band which
is
so religious you know to do for cocktail
hour
steel drum band is fun for a cocktail
app very cool that's a good honestly
that's like a really elevated event
yeah and then my brothers was uh this
bar mitzvah that we went to my brothers
was abe's
auto show and it was like a car show and
i remember
you know my parents have a lot of
friends who are much richer
they had a lot more money than my
parents so my dad like borrowed like
three of his friends like fancy cars and
they had them like
in the room like on display as if you're
at a car show
that's incredible yeah
there's a boy a young man named noah who
had
his bar mitzvah in my wedding venue and
i really like the way that they set it
up so i have like
many photos of noah's bar mitzvah
that's not weird at all i just really
like how they set up the cocktail tables
and like
man noah really did it right okay
go to your next photo here oh okay i
love this
one because this is a really
this is indicative of a lot of fashion
that was happening at the time um
should we start with the cap sure yeah
so i so let's go head to toe
um i loved clothing i always did growing
up even from like
six years old on i said i'm gonna be a
movie star and i'm gonna have a fashion
line on the side and i cared about and
my mom cares a lot about clothing so
that was always big in our house
uh this hat is uh it's actually a
quarter i hat i believe i
still have it yes i remember i got it i
was so i thought it was like the coolest
thing ever because it was from barney's
in new york i probably got this the
[ __ ] day i auditioned for when i got
rejected from american idol i was like
well you know what here's what i'm going
to say reuben studdard would never wear
this
reuben would never wear this no and
that's why i discovered myself
um yeah no the hat i don't know i don't
even know if i
i guess my mom always told me i looked
great in hats
so this was the hat i guess i chose but
this outfit the hat is like
looks like winter the rest of the alpha
is like what i don't know what season
this was taken
in that was a huge that was a huge thing
i feel
in the early 2000s is like i have on
shorts but i do
have on a long sleeve shirt i'm wearing
a knit hat
i remember layering like no matter what
long sleeve short sleeve tank top we
always had like multiple layers on
uh not for and not for warmth that was
for fashion right we always like the
layers this was like a white tank top
under like a lacy like
cool long sleeve and i probably had a
bra also on like that had like other
straps um
this is in my sister's bedroom okay the
shorts crack me up i feel like if we put
a boot on this
this is very like lindsay lohan at the
premiere of mean girls
and i'm very tan i mean i always had
like you know kind of dark skin but i
feel like
i did go through a moment in high school
where uh self tanner was introduced to
me
and i remember i went i discovered it
with my my friend and i went to florida
to visit our grandmas they lived in the
same like complex and it rained and we
were like we can't
go home from florida without a tan
because it rained
and i bought a bottle of self tanner and
i clearly think i'm still like
using it here i'm like a dark weird
color
it's did you ever do tanning bed
no not really my mom is like a cancer
survivor and she's very strict so i
wasn't allowed to do that i did in
college a little bit because i was like
[ __ ] that i'm a adult now i never did it
but it was because i lived in the emo
world the pale
pale world i had a little i have i was
under a little parasol
honestly that's why you look so young
and beautiful now like i
you know could use botox although the
self tanner you know is
is not baking in the sun so yeah no self
tanner is good
self tanner is the right option were you
a big unrequited crush person
like are you like pining after there was
an older guy i loved and i remember my
like
one of my best friends and i when i had
my car
we'd like drive past his street and now
i sound like driver's license girl but
we would literally
drive past the street and we'd be
listening to avril lavigne it's like
very vivid in my memory and we'd be like
he's home
oh my god and then we'd be like we gotta
go like he's gonna see our car
you know and we were so worried um
meanwhile i did have sex with him like
during a thanksgiving break like
sophomore year of college
you did it so many people don't don't
get to do that and you did it
congratulations anna and then i remember
thinking i'm so glad i had that done
and i actually don't like him anymore
like i'm fine now
[Laughter]
how did you how did you set it up well
we were always like
friends and i remember there was like a
party happening like
thanksgiving eve was like a big night
and i i didn't go to like the bars or
whatever but like the theater
kids had like a house party you know
like someone was like my parents are
like not here like
so we all were at someone's house and i
remember we just like hooked up and i
had already
had sex at that point for a couple years
you know so i was like
sophomore year of college but i've
already had sex a couple times
i did have sex in high school i didn't
go to college a virgin i wasn't like
but i yeah so who did you have sex with
in high school the summer boyfriend
yes yes and what um what was
were you just like i just want to do
this before high school or did you truly
feel that he was the one
no i just we planned he lived in new
york
we planned it on aim i just wanted to
lose my virginity before college because
i was afraid if i went to college
i'd like get drunk in a cvs or like i'd
get drunk i'd go to like a
7 11 and like someone would take me home
and like i wouldn't remember my night
and i was like
i was like i'm gonna be taken advantage
of if i don't know what i'm doing
and so we planned it on aim that was the
best thing ever because i lost my
virginity in
the uh hilton hotel in midtown manhattan
as a 17 year old from philadelphia
ah and you know what i was like no way
you're the first
there's no way you're the first
silly 17 year old to lose her virginity
in that hilton
i also wonder like how many virginity
losses
aim facilitated i know so many
yeah millions an entire generation's
worth of virginity is lost
so [ __ ] funny yeah no he told me he
was like we should have a sleepover and
like with a winky face and like you know
what that means
that's not a sleepover no hello that's a
no
sleepover i know and then like my
friends and i we like met up with him in
the east village
i was so young i didn't even know what
the east village was at like a [ __ ]
shitty like sushi place that served 17
year olds alcohol
and he told me his he got a hotel room
on his dad's credit card
and i was like i was panicked i was like
what did he tell his dad and like would
he get a refund if i don't go
like i don't i don't know and like i so
many questions went through it was the
least romantic experience of my life but
it feels very i i think that this
happens a lot though with virginity loss
is like
it does end up kind of being
transactional yeah and that's
okay it's like well it's not good
yeah like you're not gonna have great
sex
but at the best case scenario
you're gonna have a not harmful
experience with someone else
who wants to learn what's up with you
that's kind of hard you know you just
yeah
you just want to it's like graduating to
a new level of like adulthood
all right so we've got one more photo
from you and it goes back to your
theater days i believe so i have a guess
as to what we're looking at here but
oh yeah i guess will you guess is this
snoopy
and you're a good man charlie brown yes
oh yes
of course i mean the red the red you
know house gives it away
the the red house the overalls are
classic
for snoopy in this show so what year is
this
okay everything this is at camp so
i told you i'm a huge camp person camp
was a big part of my life in
my teenage years and uh here's the thing
at school i didn't get the leads until
senior year i mean i had that god spell
song and i was like an understudy and
pippin and then
i was the lead in guys and dolls i'll
give you that i'll give them that
camp as you should be as i was yes
adelaide was
but i was born to play that role i love
i love i love adelaide and guys and
dolls
it was like i i went in and sang the
song for my audition i was like there's
no
it's a no-brainer if anyone gets to
stroll over me like i will quit high
school
yeah that's it but so at camp
i went to an all girls camp so at camp
for some reason
i mean i know they gave me the funny
roles but they always gave me the boy
roles and i was a very girly girl and i
was like ugh and they'd fit me for my
suit we had to like slow dance with the
girl like literally
picture in all girls production of the
music man i was
marcellus okay like and my resume and i
had a resume because i wanted to be a
real actor
my resume was all boy rolls from camp
like i was harvey johnson in bye bye
birdie like
i it's very funny to me there are a lot
of plays where
gender bending the roles or
like you there are just a lot of female
roles it's very funny to me that they're
picking ones like
the music man and by my birdie yes
lead men which are led by men and not
female shows yeah
yeah like there are a lot annie annie
makes sense
for an all-girls camp right yeah if you
have a girl playing daddy warbucks
whatever i mean
good man charlie brown makes sense we
could throw a seussical in there
yeah yeah so i had all these boy rolls
this was my last summer at camp and i
was like
i came in hot i was like oh we're doing
you're a good man charlie brown that's
two female roles i will be one of them
and i i remember just being like this is
my year this is you know i've always
been a boy
this summer it's my last summer i'm 15
years old i'm like i'm gonna get the
girl one of the girl roles
did you want lucy either i liked sally
too because i loved christian chenoweth
i was like
oh my god and she played it so i
literally was like i'll go for either i
don't remember what i auditioned with
and i remember seeing this and i'm like
they didn't even give me a man they gave
me the [ __ ]
dog male dog
because they always were like she's
funny she should play the funny roles
and they're usually
boy rolls and i was like i just want to
be a pretty injunu
so yeah they gave me the the dog this is
the best though
you can't really tell from this picture
very well but i
uh boycotted costuming so the costume
department had a costume for me to play
snoopy and i was like
no snoopy doesn't need a gender
i will play snoopy as the girl that i
am and so i am wearing like a tight
tight wife beater and like juicy couture
white
like cute like capris and i have like my
cool saucony
sneakers and i was like they were like
in the ears and i was like i have hair i
will wear pigtails and
my choker will just be my collar i was
the sexiest
snoopy i you could be i was like
i was like girls wish they were snoopy
lucy's got some frumpy-ass dress
you can see my figure and this outfit
so you sexed up snoopy i did
that i did [ __ ] incredible i was like
they're not gonna give me the girl i
will be a girl
that's how you [ __ ] do it you say
i will wear juicy couture as snoopy and
i will have gorgeous
pigtails as my ears yeah i was like i'll
just blow dry them really
full and they'll just be the ears and
it'll look gorgeous
as a dog and i had like and it did this
red is snoopy to me immediately
i saw the picture and i said who is that
that's snoopy
thank you and snoopy is a great part in
the show there's two really fun songs
you know i had a lot of fun doing it and
i remember like thinking like oh it's
actually a really good role but i
i was so mad at first that i was like
i'll make this how i want it to be
that's that's a [ __ ] incredible story
i feel like this is actually the perfect
place for us to
round everything out by asking you
our final question okay which is
if you could talk to teen anna today
what would you tell her
okay i did this recently i would say
don't worry about anything right now
because when you get older
[ __ ] will happen that you really need to
worry about i was always very stressed
out you can tell by my
journals and everything i was always
like worried about my future
i would also say uh you know what kiss a
boy
uh just try it you know don't don't you
don't need to wait you don't need to
play
so hard to get have fun with boys
and i would say uh you know you don't
need to
um you're gonna get the right roles for
you you don't need to put all your eggs
in the basket of a [ __ ] musical at
high school
even though it seems like the most
important thing at the time you will
find your way eventually i guess yeah
yeah that's beautiful that's beautiful i
love it anna this is a great episode
so fun i feel like there's so much other
stuff i want to talk to you about so
we'll have to have you back but for
everyone listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you